so yeah we have a full program and
almost all of the speakers are here
which is great because it's it's
everybody's across the world and
some people are even attending
so yes i don't want to take time away
from the actual uh speakers so we'll uh
just
follow the schedule here i will have
five talks and they're all going to be
exciting so i hope you all enjoy
so let me unshare
oh
and
you you can start
all right thank you
all right
is it
a full
screen other than that
can you see my screen probably
yeah now it's working
all right okay
so yeah thank you all for coming i'm
tashan the grad student at university of
chicago and i'll be talking about our
work on explicit obedient diffs and
quantum ldpg codes the joint work with
fernando ryan pedro
and mother
so
a one-sided summary is that we construct
symmetric expanders
uh using
the randomized group baselifts so in
this talk i'll talk about why they are
interesting and how exactly do we do
that
so the outline is as follows i'll
introduce the problem and state some
motivation then i'll define these group
based lists
and quickly give a history
and then mention this with an
application
and conclude with some open problems
so i mentioned two nice graph properties
so the first is expansion
uh you might all be familiar with it
it's a notion that
captures how well connected your graph
is so for example how quickly random
works mix on your graph
and on the other hand
we have the notion of symmetry
so this graph intuitively has a cyclic
symmetry and more formally we say that
z6 can be embedded in the automorphism
group of the graph
which means that this is just the group
of all isomorphisms of the graph
right so if this occurs we say that the
graph has symmetries of z6
all right so individually these
questions have been well studied so by
now we know a lot of explicit
constructions of sparse expander graphs
so constant degree expanded graphs that
are very well connected
and
we have classical results which says
that for any finite group h you can
explicitly come up with a graph whose
automorphism group is exactly the
group edge
right so individually we kind of know
the answer to these questions
and
the question that we ask is can we have
both simultaneously
right
so now why would
we do that
so let's look at a couple reasons why
i'm interested in like this problem and
our motivation comes from a recent
collection of results on quantum ldpc
codes
so
uh so a generic uh result is that if you
take two codes which have a symmetry of
a certain group h
then you can uh combine them in a using
a quotient tensor product which depends
on the group to come up with a quantum
code right so
uh this is first defined in this work of
hastings cyan o'donnell uh and used also
by vandal evan kalachev for the cycling
group and this led to quantum codes
whose distance uh preceded
uh the known predecessors by uh quite a
lot
and the recent breakthrough works of
pancreatic karachev and venus near
what's key and moses
uh show that
you can consider constantly locally
testable codes and good quantum ldpc
codes via this kind of a construction
but now the group is a non-abelian
matrix group psl to ft
right so here it is key that you have
both expansion in the graph because
these codes are constructed via the
expander codes framework of systems
fieldman so you need expansion to prove
distance properties and you need
symmetries for the code to have symmetry
and for such a product to even be
defined
so this was our key motivation
another interesting work
on these lines is the recent work of
gold directly and rickerson
uh which construct expanded graphs which
have trivial automorphism so they have
no non-trivial isomorphisms and they use
this to construct some lower bounds in
property testing
so the key takeaway here is that um
while expansion is great uh it's better
it can be much better to have control
over the symmetries of the class
right
so
a bit more formally we say that we want
to answer the following question for a
given family of groups h n
can you explicitly construct a family of
expanders g n
such that g n has symmetries of h or h n
is the subgroup of the automorphism
group of this
throughout the talk whenever i say
explicitly i mean uh polynomial time in
the output in the size of your output
graph gn but there are stronger notions
of explicitness uh that we have
yeah ui just mentioned there's another
recent construction and that also uses
the same kind of product
um yeah so now this is the key uh tool
that we use uh is called a group
baselift so lifting essentially takes a
small graph g and lifts it up to a
larger graph
as your s so how do we do this
you take each vertex in a graph and
replace it by l copies so l is one of
the parameters
and you replace every edge here by a
perfect matching
now this perfect matching is given by
the signing function which assigns to
each edge a permutation
and when you have an h comma l if we
restrict these permutations to line the
subgroup h
right so this signing function defines
the lift of the graph therefore we
denote the lifted graph by g of s
now why is this a nice operation so it
has been classically studied in math
like under the name of covering maps
but
for us it's important for the following
reasons you can explicitly characterize
the spectrum of the lifted graph
so if you know the signing function you
can have a fairly explicit
characterization of this lift which is
useful to prove expansion it preserves
degree ah from what we saw and most
importantly for us if a group is a
billion then the lifted graph has a
symmetry of h because h acts on the l
copies of a vertex and because of
abelian uh nature of the group this uh
translates to actually a group a graph
all right
so
let's look at a quick history of lifting
in our cs constant context so mostly
people have looked at two lifts because
like i said the degree is preserved so
you can construct an infinite tar of
such tips
so it is introduced by below and lineal
and the work on international
polynomials and the recent very nice
work of monthly hodon and paradise whose
techniques we build on
have used this framework to construct
expanders
but on the group based sites we don't
really have a lot of
explicit results
so hall pudder and salmon uh showed that
the interlacing polynomial machinery of
marcus spielman
can be generalized to certain
non-nabillion groups for some
family of groups edge
but they are
specifically non-ability
and the recent work of agrawal
chandrasekharan kola and madan showed
that if you want to look at just the
cycling group
then random lifts of even exponential
size are expanding
so this is far right so
going a lot from two lifts all the way
to two to the n roughly
you can uh they are expanding
and they also complement this with the
badger result
so beyond a certain exponential again in
n you cannot do much better no matter
what a billion group you take
and this is false for non-billion groups
non-ability groups you can kind of lift
arbitrarily
all right so now the question uh more
concrete question is can we explicitly
construct these lifts for larger lift
sizes so can we do this for l line from
three all the way to this bound
so now i state our results so
we answer this question
for a large range
so here l goes from 2 all the way to
this impossibility barrier
by a c k m
so the green region here is slightly
slop exponential so
a 2 to the n to the sum fixed constant
or the region where it's exactly
exponential 2 to the theta so we show
that for large enough n and d
and this nice l so l in this green
region we can explicitly construct
expanding graphs that are zl comma
ellipse
and here there's nothing special about
the cyclic group so like most results
you can generalize this to any
transitivity is necessary for it to be
connected
right
and here some of these results are two
for any degree but in certain ranges you
really need to be degree
all right so one application of this is
explicitly ldpc codes so using the
randomized constructions of panel even
collagen
we can use our explicit expanders to
convert the results to explicit
constructions so
you you can have good quasi-cyclic npc
codes so these are codes that are used a
lot in practice for example the 5g
spectrum uses these codes and now you
can have good codes
where you have the freedom to choose
your circular and sizes so here the
circulation size depends on how much
how large you can lift your parameter l
and on the quantum side you can
construct almost good quantum led codes
so you have constant rate and almost
linear distance
of n by log n and this is actually due
to an improvement in the result of pk
21 so earlier you have weaker results
but now you can use this to construct
almost good quantum and vpc ports
so yeah that is all i have there are a
bunch of natural open problems here you
can try to make this construction
strongly explicit uh you can try to uh
fill in the gap that we have right now
maybe with a unified proof so our proof
technique is uh varies with the
parameter l so can you unify that and
can you generalize this to uh other
interesting families of non-abusing
groups so
thank you for your time yeah feel free
to ask me questions
yeah thanks so many questions
so how many different constructions do
you have like you mentioned there are
two ranges and then maybe
yes so actually the construction uh
there are two of them so let me
so here
the construction uh is kind of like
there are two constructions but the
analysis is split into like three parts
so i can quickly
show you one of the slides okay can you
see this right
yeah so here we have
we have like three kind of regimes where
we do analysis and that leads to
different kind of uh spectral bounds so
we have like uh
almost in a certain range
uh like near ramanujan or whatever
that's called and like
just expansion in one of the other
images so the analysis varies but uh the
technique is unified here but here the
technique is different
yeah
and also the dynamism tools are kind of
different
but
broadly i'd say
okay so any more uh questions
okay so let's uh virtually thank dushan
i think that's all
let me start sharing the screen
okay
so i hope the screen is visible so let
me uh so let's get started so
so so thank you for joining uh so this
is uh this is joint work with uh andre
yual yual abi and akshay
and the title of the work is bounded and
distinguishability from simple sources
and i'm and i'm dinesh
so let's get started with some simple
definitions
so let's say
z is a distribution over
over n bit strings and you say that z is
k y is independent if every k coordinate
every k coordinate looks uniform so we
have an example here
so let's say the distribution is a 1 b 1
a 1 plus b 1 a 2 b 2 a 2 plus b 2 and so
on then
this distribution is is two y
independent and it's it's not requires
independent because of these three
dependents uh moving on let's uh let's
look at the second ah notion which is
the notion of k y and distinguishability
so ah so you have a pair of
distributions x and y uh is said to be
supported over some some some ended
strings is said to be k by some
distinguishable if every k ah
coordinates are identically distributed
um so here we have an example so let's
uh look at the previous distribution for
n equal to 3 and
take x to be
the distribution conditioned on the ace
summing to 0 and the second distribution
to be the
the distribution c with a summit one
uh so
if you look at any two uh locations
either it is it is fresh random bits or
there is a uh
or there is a fresh random bit that is
getting added to uh like where this plus
is
plus is modulo 2
addition so so every two locations are
going to ah look uniform and for both x
and y and
it will be so it will be two wise
indistinguishable and it is
not three ways in distinguishable
because you look at a1 a2 a3 for the
first distribution it will sum up is
zero and for the second one it will be
one so so this could be generalized to
sort of say that
if you repeat it enough number of times
then you
um
sorry yeah so uh if you repeat enough
number of times then you
n number of times and you get an n minus
one y's in distribution
uh pair
so next what we want to talk about is
this is this nice result uh due to
driver man so
what did uh protourman show so so
suppose you have a circuit c and you
consider the experiment where you give
it a ky's independent distribution and
the other experiment where you give a
uniform distribution and you uh you try
to see if the circuit is able to tell
these two distributions apart and what
bravo mentioned is that
so you if you look at any polylog and
wise independent distribution and if you
look at any poly size ac 0 circuit
the circuit will not be able to tell
apart between these two distributions
and
the measure that we
that we are interested in is this
distinguishing advantage and
and think of this so for the setting
that we are considering think of this
this advantage to be something which is
vanishing so uh motivated by uh uh some
application certain applications in
cryptography uh bogdanovich and viola
asked if the same results if you replace
independence
by indistinguishability so
ah so and
going ahead they they showed that
this is not the case
and
this follows by this result of uh nissan
and security who showed uh uh
polynomials who showed a explicit who
described a polynomial which uh agrees
with uh r on
on all things it's close to or on all
the inputs and you can replace you can
buy an lp durability argument you can
translate this for all statement to
existence of these two distributions
which are square root and wise uh
indistinguishable but
r can distribute them so even a simple r
function can distribute so so this tells
that
if you want to have a brevard style
theorem it will require that you
you have a root and wise
in distinctivity so
so one difficulty one
sort of an issue with this result not an
issue but
[Music]
one sort of a drawback that one could
say is that this distribution is
somewhat hooked up it's a bit artificial
so
it's a bit so then one what we ask in
this work is is it that
braverman's theorem hold because this
distribution is somewhat complex so so
does government serum hold if you
if you if you have simple sources that
is if you insist that
the sources can be sampled by
given iid source of id random bits so
some of the examples that we consider
are local sources where each of the
source bit is
a function of constant many random bits
linear sources where it is a linear
function of the random bits quadratic
sources where it's a quadratic function
of random bits
so ah so having said this
let me just give a
motivation as to as to where k y is in
distribution with player into
cryptography i did mention it erases in
the cryptography so it actually erases
in the context of secret sharing so
let's say you have this one bit that you
have to share with multiple parties and
with many parties and you want to make
sure that only r of these parties could
reconstruct the secret while all other
parties with k ls nr it doesn't learn
anything about the secret um so so here
is a pair of k was indistinguishable
descriptions that come up so if you take
x to be the share of the secrets uh
where the secret is zero uh as one
distribution and the share of the secret
when the secret is one so this pair uh
so this so this pair of distributions is
um this k by s distribution so that's a
and sort of the the indisputability part
comes because of this requirement that
no
no k parties get to learn
about the secret um so what does this
tell you this tell you that if you can
come up with a
with a small circuit that that is able
to distinguish two [ __ ] in the
distinction build simple k y sensing
shape distributions then the circuit
would form the reconstruction could be
used for the reconstruction and the fact
that the
the distributions are simple
gives you an easy way to distribute a
secret um so this is if you can do the
if you can uh say that a prior man's
style theorem does not hold uh on the
other hand if
if you can indeed show that they hold it
has applications to leakage resilience
and secure multi-party computation so i
won't go into the details but ah
but yeah so this is there are
[Music]
there are these nice applications and
having said this ah so here are our ah
results so um so the first we show uh so
the table shows a set of uh sources and
set of distinguishes that these sources
uh uh distinguishes that uh that are
fooled by these sources that is they
cannot tell apart uh any for instance um
an or distinguisher cannot uh tell apart
uh
uh two [ __ ] and distinguishable uh
uh simple sources where uh they are of
constant degree uh or locality where and
k is constant
and for depth one sources uh and for k
is equal to log log n uh
it can be shown that or fools them and
this result could be shown to be tight
meaning for depth 2 this is not the case
and
for the last two results in fact one of
the
it suffices if one of the
sources is
simple you don't need both of them to be
simple and in all these think of the
distinguishing advantage to be a
constant um and
on the
so so this is we call these to be the
negative results so since they don't
give any secret sharing scheme while uh
you have a
we could show that there exist a simple
source of which could be sampled by ah
polynomials of which could be sampled by
upper limits of degree log n which r can
distinguish uh for k equal to root n and
um so these are uh so they're
efficiently samplable so um so moving
ahead we
so we so this we also have uh sort of an
excuse for why we couldn't reach our
target where why couldn't we show
for a0 distinguishes
[Music]
theorem so it turns out that
so we could connect this question
with several other ah related questions
and one of them turns out to be uh turns
out to tell that if if braverman's cell
theorem holds ah that is you cannot
distinguish two uh linear uh uh
indistinguishable pair of sources by ah
by s zero circuits then that would mean
that inner product cannot be computed by
h 0 with
leaf parity so this is something that we
do not know how to show
with the current set of techniques and
this problem again
did show up in in the first session in
michael leisure has talked so
and this is believed to be hard so so
this sort of justifies why ah one would
not
sort of
sort of tells why we
are unable to show it
so uh to conclude um let me just give a
couple of uh problems so one of the uh
results that we had with the r is is
that we could show uh uh like login
degree sources that
that r can
log in degree simple sources which are
can fool
[Music]
and the natural equation is is this is
this the best can you reduce a degree we
could show that you need ground constant
we can show that it's non-constant but
uh is log n indeed uh can you improve
this log n and uh there are there are
several conjectures that uh that we
could show is related to this question
of uh uh braverman's theorem for
indistinguishable resources but we do
not know if all of them are equivalent
so can we show that
those are equivalent that's one question
and the last one is
there is no barrier that is known if you
if you insist that if you have the
sources to be local and if you could
show that a0 uh
distinguish if there is an a0
distinguisher that can distinguish
local simple sources then that would
translate to a secret sharing scheme
with local sharing and
ac 0 reconstruction
so uh so that
so that that's all that i have to say uh
thank you
okay so let's thank ganesh
we have time for one
question if anybody has any
yeah any questions
even whether maybe a comment
okay well if you think of something then
you can you can should demand an email
yeah
yeah so then maybe
so you want shall i stop sharing
yeah please stop sharing and then
marshall can do the next sticker
sure
that's about space
on the space telescope yeah
okay can you all uh see my slides
looks great
okay
excellent um unfortunately i have a menu
blocking things but okay
um all right so i'm going to tell you
about randomness extraction from uh
somewhat dependent sources and this is
joint work with odette goldrick and tal
malkin
[Music]
and so what is the problem of randomness
extraction so random extraction we want
to convert some weak natural source of
entropy into a uniformly random bit
string
by applying a deterministic function to
this natural source okay randomness is
undoubtedly uh very important in
computation so this probably but natural
sources tend to look very different than
uh random coin flips um
and how do we model uh this is probably
all a review for most of you but how do
we model uh what is a minimal assumption
that we would like to make about these
natural entropy sources that they're
unpredictable that they have what's
called min entropy so a source has mean
entropy at least k
if no outcome occurs with probability
greater than two to the minus k you can
think of this as a worst case version of
shannon entropy
okay so there's two main branches of
research
in the domain randomness extraction and
one study is what's called seeded
extractors so here you're sort of
assuming as little as possible about
your source just that it has some
entropy
unfortunately extracting from just one
in this context is impossible so in
seated extractors you assume you have
access to a uniformly random seed so if
our goal though is to turn you know
weekly random natural sources into
purely random bit strings where are you
going to get this random seed from in
the first place so the second line of
research or principal branch research
there's other
branches here that i'm not mentioning is
on two what's called two source
extractors so here you have two
independent sources each with min
entropy
so this is great we these you can have
deterministic extractors here but
unfortunately you have to make this
independence assumption
and
perhaps in certain situations this
this may not be
an appropriate assumption so in this
work we ask this sort of natural
question can we relax this independence
assumption
okay so it's a natural question in fact
it's so natural that it was actually
asked in the works that introduced this
second branch of research into two sorts
of instructors so penny shore and audit
goldreich in 1985 proved
this negative result
which very informally stated said that
if the two sources have even very small
dependents then extraction becomes
impossible
and it seems like as a consequence of
this
theorem
no one sort of did any research in this
direction for the past 40 years
even though it seems like a natural
question but you might be asking
yourself
what do you mean by
small dependence so it's very clear what
it means if two sources are independent
or if they're not independent what does
it mean for them to have small
dependents and sort of in this work the
sort of what we're doing is we're sort
of looking at what it means for two
sources to have small dependents
systematically
in the context of randomness extraction
okay
so what we do is we introduce three
different models of limited dependence
between sources so one we call bounded
coordination
another we call bounded cross influence
and another we call bounded mutual
information
you can guess what some of these things
might mean
and in all of these k all the three of
these models if t equals zero just a
sort of a sanity check if t equals zero
uh the sources you require the case of
independent sources and if t equals k
sort of the mean entropy bound of the
the the two sources
uh then you recover the case of the
identical two identical sources or the
single which is effectively the single
source case
and these models on the left we have
sort of the the most
uh
the least general sorry uh
model of limited dependence and we have
this sort of sequence of containment so
on the right this mutual bounded neutral
information is sort of the most general
so we have these containments within
where you if you fix a t then these
containments hold
um or
in the second case between one and two
it's actually an approximate containment
but
and we want to look at these models
uh
in the context of randomness extraction
or that's what i promised you um so we
showed that in the first only in the
first model can you have any hope of
extracting
the second and third models there's no
hope of extracting
um
and you might want to say okay
let's give up but instead we we
look at a weaker notion the notion of
randomness condensers so in a randomness
condenser imagine you have some huge
natural source of entropy but the
entropy is like very sparsely
distributed so k your main entropy bound
is much much less than the size of the
source so what the condenser is is again
a deterministic function and it just
sort of compresses this source down such
that the main entropy of the output is
is is very high almost
the the length of the source
okay
and we showed it in fact in the second
case even though you can't extract you
can condense and you can condense pretty
well so if t is pretty small your
condenser is pretty good the mean
entropy bound is almost what you what
did you want the loss of the condenser
the deficiency of the condenser is t
and for the third model like we saw that
you can also condense
but qualitatively worse
than in the second case
and uh
the uh sort of more technically what
this means is that the the deficiency of
the condenser is uh inversely
proportional to the air it's error but
i'm not i'm not going to go too into any
parameters in this talk instead i want
to just spend my remaining time telling
you exactly what these models are
and refer you to the full paper to to to
learn more about the actual results
so
our first model is what we call t
coordinated sources so we say that x and
y two sources are t coordinated if there
exists this like coordinating random
variable z which has support size
uh at most two to the t so you can write
it down outputs of two z and like as two
bit strings and if i condition on any
output of z x and y become fully
independent
okay
and this is the model again where you
can extract and an alternate view an
equivalent view of t coordinated sources
we can imagine uh protocols alice and
bob two-party protocols where alice and
bob instead of
trying to compute some function they're
trying to sample the sources they have
alice has private coins bob has private
coins and they're trying to sample two
sources
and so the t coordinated sources
correspond to sources which can be
generated by such protocols where alice
and bob communicate at most t bits
so it has this sort of semantic nice
semantic interpretation
okay so that's the first model the
second model we call a cross influence
and so here here we're going to we have
this we're going to imagine that our
sources are generated by these two
functions x and y that take in uniformly
random inputs
we'll think of like one input like rx is
sort of being approximately local to x
and r y is local to y we want to bound
the influence of y on x and x on y so
what do we mean by
the influence here what do we mean by
the influence of r y on x we say that
the influence of our y on x is at most t
if if we fix any sort of
particular rx and ry
and we
then the probability that
the output of this function x changes if
we re-randomize
uh our y
uh is bounded away from one by two to
the minus t
okay
and so this is a definition of influence
sort of inspired by worst-case
notions
elsewhere
and
and t cross-influence is just we say
that two sources have t-cross-influence
if there exists these two generating
functions x and y such that the
influence of our y on x plus the
influence of our x on y is at most t
okay so if we sum up the collective
influences always it must er is at most
right so whereas the first model sort of
captured
essentially where bounded coordination
captured like potential influence of one
source on the other this is sort of
capturing the actual
influence of one source on the other
is that's one interpretation
um and so our third uh model of uh
bounded dependence probably needs no
introduction um is t mutual information
so right here we have the definition
mutual information it's the you know the
individual entropy shannon entropy of x
plus the shannon entropy of y minus the
shannon entropy of the joint
distribution we say they have t mutual
information if we can bound this
quantity by t
and again this model has this natural
semantic interpretation corresponds to
alice and bob generating protocols where
they reveal it most t bits about
their source to the other party
okay
so i think that's about my time
unfortunately
so i'll leave you with this slide and a
link on the bottom to the the full
version of the paper which has a lot
more
details and intuition
including a fourth model
called team and entropy loss
and
invite you to explore this
more fully
thanks
so okay so thank marshall
questions yeah yeah for the t-bounded
coordination are you just saying that
conditioned on this
you know coordinating random variable
you have two independent sources and
then you just reduce to the independent
source case or okay
yes yes so so extraction is very easy
because these sources are like convex
combinations of uh
independent sources if that's what
are you asking about the upper bound for
how to extract such a thing
right i'm just clarifying all right
and and for the other ones are
are they just are they reductions to
other cases oh right so all of all of
our upper bounds are actually just by
applying a generic
two source condenser with like
independent two independent source
condenser
to to the model and we show lower bounds
that basically
constructing some tailor-made condenser
won't help you so this is this is
effectively optimal so yeah you just
pick your pick your favorites to source
extractor or two-source condenser and
apply it and that will be
as
the best you can do
well assuming that it's already optimal
i guess for a two-source case
thanks
yes so your your second model is the
weakest model where this kind of
argument works
the third model the third model you can
also condense uh but it's qualitatively
worse
yeah
the the the deficiency of the condenser
is is much higher
and the deficiency of a condenser is
like how far
away the outputs mean entropy is from
sort of the optimal
which is the length of the output
okay any more
questions
are there any natural problems here
that you wanted to
solve uh
i
coming out of this uh
i think there there aren't a
lot there aren't any natural open
problems from the i mean you could
consider other notions i think of
of
limited dependence perhaps
that might be interesting um out of here
there's there's maybe some some minor
questions of tightening up the the
bounds but uh
um yeah i don't have it i don't have any
particularly compelling uh examples
unfortunately
um on hand
okay thank you now that in the third
model that you can't condense uh
better
well yeah we have a lower balance so you
can't condense better
yeah
i guess yeah so the i mean right
i mean so the open problems here reduce
i guess to constructing better to source
extractors yeah
so so by studying in some sense so if
you study you just can focus on two
source extractors you'll do better in
all of these cases
okay so uh thanks a lot uh can you
please answer your screen
right and now jesse will talk to us
about uh something
all right thank you um
let's see
[Music]
everyone everyone can see this
yeah that's great
cool all right well uh hi i'm jesse and
today i'll be talking about the space
complexity of sampling this is joint
work with ishan chattapati and david
duckman
so complexity theory studies the
question how many computational
resources are required to complete a
certain task
now traditionally this task has been
computing a boolean function f
and in order to formalize the notion of
a resource what we usually do is fix
some computational models curly c which
will have some natural size parameter
which corresponds nicely to some
resource
so then given a so-called computer c in
this computational class
we say that it computes the function f
if
for every input string x
the output of c on x is the same thing
as f of x of course
then given this formalization the
question becomes what is the smallest
computer in our class that computes the
function f
and we can call this question the
complexity of computing
now in addition to computing a boolean
function f another task that shows up a
lot in computer science is sampling from
a distribution q
and so it's natural then to ask how
powerful our favorite computational
models for the alternative task sampling
so inspired by two earlier works in 2012
viola launched a systematic study into
this question
in order to formalize this question what
you do is you take one of your
computational models from before in a
computer c from that model
but now instead of feeding it a fixed
input string x what you do is you feed
it a uniformly random input string big x
then we say that the computer c samples
the distribution q
if the output of c on this uniform
string is distributed identically to q
and of course the question then becomes
what is the smallest computer in our
class that can sample this distribution
and we can call this the complexity of
sampling or the complexity of
distributions
so beyond these two specific questions
these two fields are generally
interested in understanding
the power of various computational
models for the task of computing and the
task of sampling
so in this work we focus on the library
so recently there have been a lot of
really exciting papers on the complexity
of sampling
that help us you know understand our
classical models for this new task
but while significant progress has been
made our results are still only known
for a few computational models like ac 0
circuits and communication protocols and
in particular not much is known about
the complexity of sampling with limited
memory
so the goal this worked is to kind of
fill in this gap and study the so-called
space complexity of sampling
now before i can tell you our results i
need to answer two questions
so the first question is what models
should we use for sampling and limited
memory and then once we know that we
need to understand what are some
interesting questions to ask about
sampling with this model
so the model that we use for sampling in
limited memory is just the classical
model of read one's branching programs
which we slightly generalize in a
natural way so that they can output
multiple bits
and if you're not familiar with what the
robp is
all you need to know now is that it has
an important parameter called this width
w which roughly corresponds to the
number of bits of memory that this
program can use to compute its function
or sample with the output distribution
and if you don't want to remember that
all you need to remember here is that
more width means more memory which means
more power
so that's our model
um our obts and so now we can ask what
questions who are you know are
interesting to ask about sampling with
robps
so in order to figure this out we'll
revisit a paradigm that appears in a lot
of these papers on the complexity of
sampling which is that sampling is
actually easier than computing
so what we mean by this is that they're
actually functions f such that it's hard
to compute the output of f on every
single input x
but its output distribution
can be very easy to sample so as kind of
a conditional example you could think of
taking f as the inverse of a one-way
permutation
so by definition of one way f will be
extremely hard to compute but by
definition of permutation its output
will be uniform which is extremely easy
to sample
so there are explicit examples as well
so given this paradigm it turns out that
sampling lower bounds are more
challenging than classical lower bounds
to obtain
and it's been argued that pursuing
sampling lower bounds could yield new
techniques and surprising applications
so our goal in this work is to obtain
sampling lower bounds against robps
so we have two main results in this
direction so i'll introduce each and go
into a little bit of detail on each of
them so our first result is a strong
sampling lower bounds against the
natural explicit distribution for robps
so if we'd like to obtain sampling lower
bounds against robps the first question
is can we just find the distribution
that cannot be sampled so one of the
first computational models in which this
was studied was ac0 circuits
so
to make things a little more explicit
the question becomes can we find the
distribution q such that the output
distribution of any ac 0 circuit is not
exactly q
so this turns out to be actually trivial
and so in 2012 alveolar introduced the
more interesting challenge of can we
find a distribution that cannot even
approximately be sampled by ac 0
circuits
so by approximately we mean that the
output distribution of any ac 0 circuit
should be far from the distribution q
in terms of statistical distance
so later in 2012 lovett and viola
answered this question by providing a
very natural distribution q with very
strong sampling lower bounds against ac
0 cert namely sampling lower bounds that
are polynomially close to 1.
and then later in 2012 beck and
pogliazzo and lovett improve this
sampling lower bound to be exponentially
equal to one
and it's for the same distribution q and
this distribution q turns out to be very
natural it's just a uniform distribution
over a good code
so by good code we mean an error
correcting code that has linear distance
and linear dimensions
so on the other hand um
turns out that good codes are extremely
easy to sample using communication
protocols and so natural question then
is where do robps fit in this picture
and in particular are good codes hard to
sample with robp
so our first main result answers this
question and it says yes so it says that
for any good code q and any robp of with
say 2 to the 0.01 n
the output distribution of that robp is
exponentially far
from that good code
and using a known connection by viola we
automatically obtain these data
structure lower bounds against scoring
codewords
so that's our first main result
our second main result is the so-called
direct product theorem for sampling with
robps
so in order to introduce what a direct
product theorem is a question that we're
interested in is the following so
suppose that we have a distribution that
is a little bit harder to sample for
some computational model then the
question is can we use it to build
another distribution that is extremely
hard to sample for that same model
and the reason why this is and uh
furthermore we'd like q star the
distribution we build to be just a
little more complicated with q
and the reason why this is interesting
is because if we can answer this
question positively then we can use it
to strengthen separations between
complexity classes for the task of
sampling
so the answer to this question is
exactly
a direct product here so direct product
theorems are well studied for the task
computing
and here they roughly say the following
so suppose that you have a function
that's hard to compute for some
computational model then you can use it
to build a function f cross t that is
very hard to compute for the same model
and f cross p is just defined by taking
its input chopping it up into t parts
and then applying the hard function f to
each part
and one example of a direct product
theorem like this that's known for
computing zai problem
so for the task of sampling a direct
product theorem might be defined as
follows so suppose that you have some
distribution q that's hard to sample for
the class currency
then we'd like to build a distribution q
cross t that's very hard to sample for
the same class where naturally we define
q cross t to just consist of t
independent copies of q concatenated
together
now it turns out that no direct product
theorems are actually known for the task
of sampling and so our first our second
question is should we
um you know establish a direct product
theorem for this task and specifically
for our obp through you know studying
the limited memory model
so our second main result
answers this question in the positive
and it shows that for any robp of with w
if its output distribution is delta far
from q
then for any robp of with w its output
distribution is exponentially far from q
cross p
so that's our second main result
uh so kind of just to conclude here
uh we proved two main results our first
main result is a sampling lower bound
against good codes so previously this
was only known for ac zero circuits and
the sampling lower bounds that were
known were extremely strong and on the
on the other hand uh good codes are very
easy to stamp with communication
protocols
um and we show that robps behave a
little more like ac zero circuits than
communication protocols in this setting
in the sense that they have a really
hard time sampling good codes
and again using the connection of viola
both of these results have applications
and data structure workouts
so in the context of direct product
theorems nothing was previously known
for the task sampling
and we established kind of the first
direct product theorem for this task we
established it for robp
and one cool thing about our proof is
that um one of the main ingredients is a
simple new proof of another uh stamp and
lower bounds obtained for communication
protocol sampling disjoint sets
so because this is a super new area
there are a lot of interesting open
problems so
one problem is maybe can we establish
direct product theorems for other
computational models besides robps
another thing is can we kind of extend
our sampling lower bounds to work for
repay branching programs
and finally it'd be interesting to
exhibit distributions that demonstrate
separations between a power of ac0
circuits and robps for the task of
sample so it's really easy to find a
distribution you could sample an ac 0
that you can't sample with robps
but it's quite hard to show the other
way around and we don't know how to do
it yet but some advances in extractors
would answer this question for us
so that concludes my talk thanks for
listening and uh i'm happy to take any
questions
yeah thanks so we have time for maybe
one quick question
uh yeah i have a question you mentioned
that
um communication products can sample
good codes can you can you see how this
is done
uh okay um so i guess the standard model
or at least by um busan watson for
communication protocols is alice and bob
each have their own private randomness
and they could uh communicate and at the
end each one has to output a part of the
distribution
um so what you could do is they could
just not communicate at all and alice
can use all of her randomness to just
output a code with like uh 0.01 distance
and rate our rate and uh relative
distance
so bob says nothing
yeah so bob does nothing and alice just
um
outputs the code herself because it's
still good even if it has rate uh and
relative distance less than half
oh
oh i see
okay okay so it's
okay so i mean all right
yeah it seems a little bit different
cheats like maybe if you're looking for
a specific code then this one for
yeah i agree yeah
you can ask more from from the rate but
yeah i mean
i get to here soon the one when it's to
be careful about these things
yeah yeah i guess uh community there
exists a good code that they can sample
whereas robps and ac0 circuits cannot
sample any good code i guess that's the
main distinction
right
yeah thanks
okay we're a bit over time so if there
are any more questions then you can take
them offline so uh thanks again
so huanga you're last
can you see my screen
well we can't see the false no yeah now
it's working okay okay
okay hello everyone my i am
today i'm going to present to you our
work about the other cochlear physics
from the combinatorial degeneration
this is all work with matthew christian
omar fazi and jikun zaram
in this paper we contract a special
combinatorial object called the cochlear
physics
which is motivated by a central problem
in the communication complexity namely
if
we are considered a
multi-party communication complexity
on the number on the forehead model
the cognitive process
has
studied
in the some work of the shellman nina
pitasi viola and the cover
namely in the work of lina and xiaomi
they contract a lot to the
large corner visas in the into the
greece by designing efficient and nov
communication protocols
in our paper we take a different
approach namely we
consider the corner pieces on the finite
field setting and interview in this area
the method of combinator or degeneration
so what are the cognitive issues
according is the cheaper point of the
form x y
x plus lambda y and x y plus lambda
which lambda is num zero
they are many various settings of the
corner
in the intersect grid and by n
or grid over the finite group the g time
z
a subset of the boy in the z30 is cognos
3 if it does not contain 3 point of the
corner
we denote the rgb the size blast
cochlear precepts in the grid the z
times z
in our paper we uh
uh study on cognitive reset on the
finite view uh
fpn
uh namely we saw that for the
largest cognitive process in the f2n is
at least
3.39 power m which compared with the two
point s two power n
provided by
the work of the lina petersen shaman in
the
uh 2018
and for the
at the f3n
we saw there is at least seven power and
we com
which compared with the six pi
sigma n
which contracting by using the error
construction for the carb set problem
the our motivation
comes from the
minimizer deterministic communication
protocol on the of the eval function on
the
number on the forehead model in the
multi-multi-party communication
complexity
it is some work of
chandra bush and little in the
1983 and the in the work of lina fishy
and german in the 2018
they saw that any the
other quarterback can be used to the
provider communication protocol for the
eval function
that means
and is good low bar for the last corner
pieces we can make the good protocol for
the eval function
our methods can be summarized as follows
the first we describe the cognitive
recess problem as a
namely reconstructs the
hypograph with the corner
equivalent to the axis of the hypograph
and the cochlear precess is equivalent
to the individual shape in this type of
graph
the hyper graph
has the power structure
then we introduce the general method for
the contracting lab independent set in
the hyper graph
has a power tracker for the
combinatorial degeneration
okay we uh
we start with the on the direct percent
greek graph on the work of the videomon
mini into
1985
for the any the directed a secret graph
with a vertex v
then on the end copy of this graph we
can construct independent set of psi b
power n minus small or
o n
the idea as follows we consider the
the eigen symmetric of this graph and
the in in this symmetry we put all
diagonal entry equal to one because the
graph is a circular therefore the it is
tensor agency matrix is upper triangular
matrix
then if we touch the
n tensor power of the agency matrix
is it is the
agency metric of the end copy
of this graph
because the
n test power of uh
agency matrix also the upper triangular
matrix therefore uh if you take the
sub-matrix indented by the uniform n24
we can obtain the identity matrix
therefore the uh thus we can construct
the side of independent step in
on the enthalpy of this graph have the
psi equal to psi of uniform and 243.
so on the 3d form hypergraph we
generalize the
notion of
a graph to the hypergraph as follows
suppose that there are the three integer
map you want to be from the vertex
such that this certified recognition the
first for the overt v
we have the e one b plus u two v plus
three v equal to zero and there is the
bigger than zero on the of
all the s e one e two and e three
then we can contract uh on the end copy
of this hyper graph earnings set of psi
v power n minus small of n
the idea is similar
in the
graph scale we construct the agency
tensor of the
three uniform hyper graph and we put uh
on this
agency tensor uh order all the diode
diagonal entry input one
then we take the n power
sensor power
then we
consider the substance that rejected by
the uniform and tuple we
can prove the
uh
in the surface is identity
tensor
okay
let me stop here thanks for listening
okay thank you
yeah any questions
so you're constructing corner presets
but do you think this technique can be
used to construct other types of
sets which don't contain certain
configurations
yes yes
this method can be the
contracts for the
some configuration for the possible on
the l-shape
or the
or the other boy on the
buff for example
yeah
so if a geographer has a power structure
we can
contract
by this method
and any more questions
okay so let's thank all the speakers in
the session
i'll chat for all of you
and you're all welcome to join the
following session which is also the last
session so um
yeah
i enjoyed my session so thanks a lot for
everybody for
speaking and for attending
thank you
you